okay let's talk about mmobile shout out
to mmobile talking $15 a month when you
sign up for a 3month plan we're talking
about limited talk text and data mhm so
you can do all the scrolling you want
yeah even watch your videos uh my wife's
been using it for years it's fantastic
you get to keep your same phone your
same number all your contacts the only
thing that changes is your bill to get
this new customer offer and your new
three-month Unlimited Wireless plan for
just 15 bucks a month go to
mintmobile.com garbage that's
mintmobile.com garbage cut your wireless
build to just 15 bucks a month at
mintmobile.com garbage additional taxes
fees restrictions apply C mmobile for
details let's get to the show welcome to
another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals or absolute trash now here
are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite
podcast this is are you garbage oh yeah
it's that little show we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find that
at the gr to be Cy they're just a big
old piece of trash trash trash trash I'm
your host H Foy coming at you on a
beautiful day we're out back here at
toies in the new edition just got a
visit from the cops oh boy looking for
okay Federal ATF FBI alphabet boys
coming and looking for I don't know what
the hell she did maybe Good Samaritan
award or something I don't think so
usually don't s a SWAT team for
something you have a search warrant for
that Mye Coos is coming at you from
across the TBL is what we call a family
episode just the boys the bozos and the
homies just the way we like it he is the
CEO of Ru garbage he is an international
businessman he's got us going to Ireland
going over there going over paying some
Tribute back to the old country Mother
Land kicking I got to kick up some Vig
one thing I can't take away from you
you're getting me back to Ireland look
at that huh my father's smiling down
from heaven on him okay Dead Guy brought
up first 90 seconds here we go it's an
alltime record Kevin James Ryan
everybody what's up everybody thanks
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you revew subscribe on iTunes
full video available on YouTube as you
know those numbers are true to ref
cooking cooking and obviously the
greatest website of all time
www.patreon.com you garbage you go over
there you join the [__] homies
over 13,000 people on that gosh darn
Patriot arm garbage woo having a fun
time over there you can get up to two
bonus episodes every week there's a ton
of video content on there Vlogs other
goals stuff we've done it's a party
check it out also the second best
website
www.b.com you go over there you get your
brand new Ru garbage guard card game uh
with over 50 questions uh for you to
play with your friends and your family
nice little Drinking Game Party game
whatever running low too running love
moving some numbies and then also May
9th New York City New York town hall
baby our biggest show to date get them
TIY let's go grab the squad come out and
see the boys classiest place we've ever
performed yep on the great white way
this going to end up with lawyers I'm
sure somehow Broadway uhhuh and how
about a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the old magic
man speaking of Broadway works the ones
the twos the threes and the fours
crosses the t's and he dots the eyes and
he is no stranger to the boards give it
up for T-Bone MC Scruff and Doby
McMullan everybody what up boys no
trying to enjoy winter time which is a
you know the snow gets me down got a lot
going on H what the hell's with you do
all doom and gloom I'm not Doom and
Gloom I you're not happy and sunny I
have a plan to get me out okay I want to
build a jump when's the last time you
built a jump dude what a snow jump yeah
where are you going to do that Central
Park or something Central arrest you for
that what are you nuts nuts you're going
to end up in the clink with tutty
there's got to be a hillworth sledding
somewhere here down there in the
catacombs you what are you going to go
you're going to go build a jump and go
sledding I would like to you go to the
cemetery out there in uh on uh graveyard
what is it uh Jackie Robinson Parkway
yeah jump over some vampires don't let d
shv uh yeah that's not I mean I'm too
big to be doing it I'm too big and too
old I I I don't get blast right through
I don't get airb I don't get on a sled I
ain't doing a tube I ain't doing a snow
I ain't doing nothing I'm done those
days are behind me somebody asked me to
go can't be going on stage and one with
one of those [__] scooter things
somebody asked me to go ice skating the
other day I'm like are you out of your
goddamn mind life insurance what are you
crazy yeah you're too big to go ice
skate never none of that it's all done
it's all done that stuff yeah I stay on
the ground too 10 minutes on a treadmill
that's what I'll do a little incline and
do some some weights that's what I'm
doing that's it okay not doing anything
like that where I'm going to slip and
bust a hip or something man you would go
down quick I'm a fall risk yeah for sure
are you kidding me of the oics my bones
are like made out of peanut brittle
right now also if you pick up enough
momentum you might take take take out a
[__] family from Cleveland that snap
like a dried out Christmas tree you
kidding me uhuh now get off the jumps
man snowball fight with who I'm pitching
the idea right now no what no that would
end in a f fight that would end in a
fist fight I got contacts I'll fully be
stuffing rocks in there for sure dude no
but I saw that video of uh a pitcher
don't ever get into a snowball f with a
pitcher and this kid whipped one at a
fence and you heard the the snap on it
mhm woo knock your eyebrows off a scene
for M uh I tell you the one time we were
on the beach teenager you know young
teens 13 whatever it was me tight body
hanging out chicks all over you I got
the picture swimming with a shirt on and
we were like in the Water Guy boards
with a jean jacket on we were like I so
I yelled we were doing like like sand
fight like whipping like the wet sand
out each other in the water you know
what I mean oh like we were just like
you know just Gunk fight yeah Gunk fight
do that in the bay get that stink on you
but dude that's C causes a fight I
called I was like I we had been we had
done it once or twice and it was like
fun or whatever and I was like all right
sand fight and like I bent down and my
jerk off buddy was already like had the
he already had it in his hand had the
drop on you oh dude he was just waiting
for me dude I came up out of the water
and [__] glunk my eye up I couldn't
see for two weeks I dude I was sleep I
would wake up to' be puss and it was
like low tide in my [__] ey that sand
[__] gets everywhere how you get C dude
I know man it wasad I came out of the
water thinking I was Johnny cool guy and
got knocked down got sand crabs living
in your nose the all the hot chicks saw
me striking out do you ever get jammed
up in the uh in the water not like
almost drowned but like did you ever get
knocked around a little bit where you
were
scared yeah I uh yeah one time I was
Boogie boarding uh after the uh they had
left that was when like the good weight
my cousin was a bit of a surf not great
but like a surfer so they would go like
after the lifeguards were left so
because you couldn't surf during you
know there was only certain surf fees or
whatever so I would go on boogie board I
was probably seven years old or whatever
man and I called a ripper man and this
thing I nose dived and smashed my face
came up all bloody crying sand all
gunked up man embar I don't have I don't
got a good track record on the beach I
get beat up man I was petrified of that
stuff cu the ' 80s if somebody had
somebody had always the summer before
someone had gotten God out there and
they had the little cup at the grocery
store and all that [__] timy or whatever
yeah yeah he was body surfing he broke
his neck oh oh always a neck I feel like
people were breaking their necks every
week in the '90s was crazy it was ever
you're break your neck yeah yeah yeah
yeah always breaking neck so knock that
off yeah I'm enjoying the winter I like
it oh that's good I like the cold I like
the coziness I uh I got something the
other day it was a little more hard
feelings but the other day I was uh me
and the bird were walking in the dog mhm
and I have said before kind of sex term
way you said it taking the dog for a
walk and um we're walking there's like a
there's like a strip be a Street behind
a church that like the cars are
constantly getting stolen just in a bir
oh this is up in a Heights this is in
the Heights there's a Street behind the
church the cars are constantly get so
it's like one of those things of like
you walk by every day and there's a car
on cinder blocks or milk there it's
usually milk crates mhm um how do they
hold them I don't D they squash down
they're like
they just need like enough to get it off
they steal the wheels or whatever we're
still using milk crates like that as a
society they're still out there I don't
think it's just for milk it's for like a
lot like you know it's been grocery
stores are like hey here comes like
whatever's getting delivered in milk
crates no kid not like glass [__]
milk jug still banging huh I believe so
yeah good for them um whatever it's on
plastic crates that people are stealing
from whether it's like the two L ones
from the [__] you know the Pepsi guy
or whatever you know how they have like
those holy [__] those things I know
they're like Lego pieces yeah any
plastic thing that they come in that
they deliver food in at a grocery store
these people are stealing and propping
up cars to you know H it's they're not I
don't care I don't think they care what
they're using they're [__] stealing
something to get these up gaps off
they're [__] you're getting you're
getting caught on the wrong crime here
buddy they're stealing cars all right
you're like milk crates why does this
Society come it's supposed to recycle
them I know Jesus Christ talk about
getting bogged down in the details those
are for records and such I know what the
[__]
they're stealing cars how are guys in
their 20s going to
move neighborhood's going to [__] um
neighborhood is going downhill
everything's going this whatever so I'm
walking the dog and this is one of those
things of
like you live in a city long enough you
know all right this guy's up to no good
let me just walk past them whatever it
is you know a shirtless guy with a
machete he's covered in blood holding a
milk crate I think I should steer clear
you believe what they're doing with
these milk crates
sir um I don't know where you're going
with this I don't want I don't want to
he's a
criminal what do you mean where am I
going you had a mask in a sack with a
money sign on it no you know who is just
that stripe mask what was that all about
you know who's oblivious hey we're Mass
Griffin over
here come on get involved sorry back to
the milk crates Jesus Christ you know
who is oblivious to that kind of
situation who the birds no mine we CL
both CL okay yeah ah mine's walking
around and blowing daisies like get over
on this side of me in case I got to make
a move on something in case they make a
move I can throw you on the ground run
and get help real quick she's weak get
her you start mugging her hey give me
your bag give me wall lady no dude no
awareness of anything like that no I got
to I got to take get over here or like
starts walking like you know taking a
step behind
me damn I got to be able to defend
yeah sure keep it all in front of me I
only got a couple of swings in me oh
yeah that's I think that's being
generous I got one or two uhhuh hit them
with do the throat or something like
that sure karate chop he's got two moves
please
don't
security uh I'm calling the police sir I
uh so we're walking down and like it's
it's a it's a not not a hub for Crime
but there's sounds like it is there
tends to be nefarious characters cuz
there's no houses it overlooks like a
park and it's behind the church so where
you got got no wasn't the same street
but further I was uh no no no I was
right behind the police department when
they got me they don't care these people
are
walless um so uh we're walking down and
I see them so imagine it's like a it's
the street and then like the three feet
of grass sidewalk you know like sidewalk
and then maybe 10 ft of grass
and then like the back of these
buildings you know what I mean so
they're they have one of those mopeds
that everybody's riding around on mhm
and it's like off it's against the back
wall and like it's not a place somebody
would chain it's not a place these
people should be stopped with a moped
you know what I mean like there's no
reason they're all the way over there
they're not parking it they're not
unlocking it's like set it once I'll set
it a thousand times two guys on a
scooter no good no this is a Bonnie and
Clyde this is a this is either way is a
two people on a scooter are up to no
good this is a couple and you know I
guess it's just cuz like I you know I I
grew up with a lot of but like you know
the crackhead couples they're like
they're you know their their their
mission is to gather stuff for the two
of them you know what I mean they're
they're they're they're out there
collecting like [__] resources so
they can both get [__] up Scavenging
yeah they're a team together they're
operating together you know what I mean
busy day uhhuh so I I I clocked that
right away but they're in like regular
clothes they're not like home but
they're like they're you know cracky
they're they're they're moving and
shaking sketchy yeah Shifty Shifty sure
dodgy he's a little too thin he's a
little too thin and I mean you think I
got bags under my eyes this guy looked
like he was in Mike Tyson's knockout
this guy was [__] he looked like a
raccoon hey buddy little
melatonin out you got to check those
when he flies uhhuh so those are heavy
bags those are over those are over 35
lbs
Bud those come out in the those come out
in the oversized luggage carp Louis
Vuitton's hanging off your
eyes
really [__] started hitting you with
the squirt
bottle [__] get you on your toes
again big that was good uh it was all
right um better so I go [__] all right
now I got the doll I get the dog uh
what's he's thinking he's sniffing he's
like he's on the verge of taking a
taking a deuce this one right so he's
he's not paying attention really and we
clock him maybe 20 yards out we both do
but it's like sketchy couple by SK
couple and we we sketch they we clocked
them cuz they clock us they're looking
it's not just like they're looking at us
going are they looking at us are they
tracking are they looking squirrs in the
park so because they're doing something
shouldn't be doing I'm not sure what
they're doing but they're doing
something they shouldn't be doing they
weren't cheating on a test no no so
they're clocking us heavy and then like
you know turning their backs and there's
a lot of movement the one guy's got a a
a school bag she's got like a plastic
bag they have that big metal chain to
the scooter but it's not connected I
don't know if they just cut it off I
don't know what's going on and I'm not
I'm not taking the [__] time to to
figure it out but I'm like all right so
I get the dog like I pull like the half
leash up you know what I mean so I have
him like he he he was wandering before
but I get him here to be like if I need
a [__] if I got to hit him with a
sick him I'm good you know what I mean
like get him boy you think he would I
think if that guy if we started
scrapping he I don't he probably go
chase the mailman or something I think
I'd be high and dry you'd have to tell
him that guy had treats in his pocket or
something yeah yeah something you know
what I mean so you should get him a
spike collar so he looks the part to HT
myself when he told come in I'm covered
in
Band-Aid H you slept with me last night
uh so we're like all right and it was
this it was a great moment between me me
me and the lady we were both like we
both kind of made eye contact of like
keep your head on a swivel this is you
know are you going to continue to walk
by them we have to it's too weird at
this point to just stop and turn around
they've already worried about social
engagement no I'm worried about being
like they're CRA they're clearly crazy
so my it's like on the it's like we were
talking about on the sub it's like you
got to get off at a certain like you're
either in it you got to weather the
storm through it cuz if you show them
like what if he goes oh they're going to
go tell the cops I got to [__] I got
to go get them or whatever or we've just
our presence has intimidated them easy
Mark let's get them yeah something so
I'm like exactly like all right I'll
give you that these kids I'm like you
ain't [__] scaring me meanwhile I'm
[__]
myself no I wasn't scared but it's just
like all right just you know just keep
your head on a swivel type thing man and
we're walking so I'm like all right cool
we're like you know shoulder-to-shoulder
uh and right as we get to them the dog
stops to take his [__] and dude we are
literally two feet from them and they's
like how you doing like there's we have
to make some sort of [__]
conversation with these people dude it
was so awkward was eating eggshells the
guy was stunned he was like you know
have a nice day or whatever we [__]
scar I didn't I didn't pick that up that
was [__] you guys go ahead with
you're stabbing he's just pooping those
angle grinders go through that metal
like butter huh I know is that a
Milwaukee we have one at the house we're
just over here around the corner come
over any away a lot
too yeah it was brutal man it was one of
those things of like ah we're just in
this and we all kind of just like you
guys seen the lantern flies around here
a lot yeah H yeah it was one of like I
could have you pick that up I did I was
cuz also you can't show Fear I'm like
yeah I don't you're not [__] scaring
me this is my home turf I'm going to
bend down pick up my poop and get your
eyes on the whole time you're been I got
my hand on my
wallet I don't know man from this I've
never been to this part of town but what
you're describing I think I leave that
there uh sure but then I'm a criminal if
I leave it there I can get up to $150
fine in 30 days in jail I'm a bad boy
too I'm looking at him like he you you
[__]
around they go Toe to Toe with me
call me the neighborhood pooper shit's
in this whole neighborhood I never pick
it up okay let's talk about rocket money
rocket money you ever get the feeling
money's flying out the door you got a
lot of subscriptions you don't know
about you catch it every once in a while
do yourself a favor get over to Rocket
money find out what subscriptions you're
paying for and if you don't want to keep
them they can ask them right there yeah
rocket money is a personal finance app
that finds and cancels your unwanted
subscription monitors your spending and
helps lower your bills it's easy that
the the app shows you everything that
you're subscribed for you just press
cancel with just a tap there's no
getting on the phone with customer
service no sales people trying to talk
to you into staying with them it's easy
peasy I I downloaded I found out I was
subscribed to boner of the month club
they were able to cancel that without my
wife knowing about it think I signed up
for that uh rocket money has over 5
million users and has helped saved its
members an average of $720 a year God
darn it's a couple couple sheel with
over $500 million in canceled
subscriptions Hy Machi that's a lot of
scratch stop wasting money money on
things that you don't use cancel your
unwanted subscriptions by going to
Rocket money.com garbage that's rocket
money.com garbage rocket money.com
garbage do it gang they want you to
remember it so do it do it K let's talk
about tushy shout out to tushy yeah you
know what the worst is you get into the
shower you feel good you hop out and you
got to make a boom boom then the whole
process has got to start all over got
poop on your head not if you got a tushy
bday get on there you feel fresh and
clean it's the same water that comes out
of the faucet Crystal clear crystal
clean and your butthole well thank you
yeah and if you've never used a bedday
tushi is the perfect way to get into the
bedday game it's fantastic not only you
feel way cleaner throughout the day but
tushi is going to save you some serious
money the typical tushi user goes
through 75% less toilet toilet paper on
average oh my God I'm using too much
which is great for your wallet and for
the environment every tushi bedet comes
with a 30-day hassle-free warranty uh
30-day hassle-free return and a 12month
warranty come on what are you doing try
it out they're making it easy peasy
get that fresh out of the shower feeling
at hellotushy.com for a limited time our
listeners get 10% off your entire order
when you use code garbage at checkout
that's 10% off your order at hello tushi
h l l t y.com promo Cod garbage it's
time to back that ass up with confidence
girls clean that butt do it you ever
forget a bag and have to improvise oh
yeah oh yeah I've the the the most yeah
you'll leave it
you act like you're yeah you act like
you're picking it up you look around
make sure you're good coverage wise fake
bend down pick it up one time I
disassembled a a box a cigarette box and
used that I've never felt more like
mcgyver what like a pack of sigs correct
Jesus how small was the dug big dog big
dog damn had poop all over my hands yeah
uh we're lucky enough that in the
neighborhood they have a lot of the bags
like stations where people go put the
plastic bags how about getting rid of
the crackheads first a nice neighborhood
uh coffee cup works too if you don't
have anything if you're walking with
coffee you realize you're out of a bat
not a mug I'm not an animal I'm talking
about an empty coffee cup it's still
steaming yeah you
get morning you want two
scoops uh yeah coffee cup works too a
coffee cup well what's I mean what's why
is that disgusting I don't know I'm
sorry it's better than the B your your
hands don't touch it you just go you
know what's good leaving it yeah I've e
I've
I've get some nosy neighbor Jam you up
though
hey I would like to get your take on
this this is this is heavy dog dog for
business hours dog poop we do for you
when we're in the BBS we go on like
there's like a nature trail we go on a
walk and he'll poop back there yeah do I
have to pick that up yeah on the trail
not on the trail in the woods in it's in
the woods nah yeah you got to do it is
he going deep in the woods deep in the
woods that's what I'm saying yeah not
going to a cabin or anything yeah he's
not that's spend a weekend in the Pocono
he doesn't have a barrel of whiskey on
his neck yeah what do you mean deep I'm
not letting them go yeah that's cuz
that'll just that that'll start stinking
in the spring and it'll bring flies and
bugs and varmints you think that's going
to last till the spring over winter
weather no way I mean I think you're
doing it now you're going to be doing it
in the spring you got to you just made
an ass I said now he p and I'm not and
yeah I do think it'll it'll thaw in the
spring okay and it'll stink you just
responded like you had scientific data
on actually I I no poop thaws in the
summer what I I know how much poop are
you freezing I
know yeah dude you can't be doing that
you're those guys I'm not F don't paint
me with this brush smells back there
next thing you know you're pooping back
there deer pooping back there bears are
pooping back your dog is not on a deer
diet deers eat grass and leaves and
berries who knows what that hell you
ever smell a vegan a vegan poop they're
the worst poops you ever smelled I don't
think I have deer poop doesn't smell
they're little pellets Little P pells
yeah but you're not spending enough time
around to know if they smell I do you're
just making a facts to go along with it
I mean I'm not saying hey I leave it
back there like for sure but it's like
if somebody sees you on that trail not
do that they're going to yell at you
they're going to yell at me some guy on
a yell at me I'm saying no one sees me
I'm not doing it I'm doing it when no
one's here you're part of the problem
aren't you hey I'm not stealing mopeds
long up there between the church and the
over pads or you're walk nature trail 5T
off the trail in the brush is okay no I
think you're wrong to blatantly say no
about that that's insane no that's not a
gray area you can't give me that cuz
everybody walks back there to get their
exercise no one wants to smell that it's
the grayest of areas it's the grayest
it's nature it's nature you do it into a
society you don't do it in nature I
don't think so that's on The Fringe of a
society dog I've taken dumps in the
woods bro yeah
and I pick him up with a coffee
cup big Gold
Cup yeah I've only done that once not
good yeah it ain't great um but all
that's neither here nor there we got a
gosh darn Family episode as the big man
said when you sign up for patreon we
answer your garbage question on the air
oh yeah it's the best way to do it
patreon get first crack at it um all
right let's see here this one's
from Sam Tom Sam Sam
first time long time ever walk on
graduation day just to be handed a piece
of paper that says I have to come back
in the summer to make up the final
credits instead of an receiving an
actual diploma PS the guy behind me got
handed a bill for a late book instead of
his diploma the hell kind of school you
going into Jesus sounds like a pay to
play type place um no but that was a
threat that was oh that was the
lingering threat from 7th grade on
that's like getting served at your high
school graduation that sucks it's a guy
dressed up as a pizza delivery guy got
yeah yo yo alimony mhm um no that well
that yeah that was a threat you know
growing up but that was actually a
threat for me senior oh I had it too
disciplinary yeah I don't think I knew
when I if I they were going to hand me a
diploma or not really I was like third
in my class I don't think they would
have let me from the other way I don't
think they would have let me it doesn't
make sense to let you walk I get parents
in there and all that stuff I know but
if you're not graduating you shouldn't
get the if you're like hey you got to
come back in the summer and do this one
class or take this test or this extra
credit project we're going to let you
walk under the guys of you know which
like you've shown that you're going to
walk you know what I mean thank God
because I probably wouldn't have man
that was the most important thing to a
parent walking at graduation you had to
go home and tell them you aren't walking
God damn yeah that was the that was the
biggest threat it sucked ours is quick
though was yours during the day or at
night during the day ours was at night
Friday night boom we were in the car on
our way down to the Jersey Shore sheit
ass uh yeah I think mine was during the
day College was during the day too oh
yeah
going see you around ripped up my draft
card and headed on out the wild
west go get drunk at
maos we did go to MOS yeah no [__] and
they did not appreciate us being there
before the season started I can tell you
you that sure messed up our pie on purp
purpose but I don't know what to tell
you Maca Max is
unbelievable uh love that Jersey short
Pizza you're on acid man they probably
thought you were eating spaghetti it's
probably true another Porter House
please
what there too many spiders in my
pizza I mean I I just met this guy but
this pizza is making a lot of sense ours
was quick in and out yeah I don't think
ours I mean we had a big class we were
500 5 our class was where'd you fall
into that uh I was I was the real meaty
part of the I I I remember the girl that
was 505 man yeah I was I think we were
like 347 I was 343 or something like
that look at you now yeah huh still dumb
as 348 dumb as a Hammer laundry all over
the apartment you're five out of five
you're five out of five on the team what
do you mean out of our team intelligence
wise I would disagree with that strongly
okay give me a test well who do you
think you're I mean who do you think
you're smarter than on that I think
you'd be
surprised I'm asking that's not an
answer to the question you said no way
and I said okay well then statistically
there's there's five people we know who
they are who do you think you're I'm not
[__] on you you started with I was
345 out of 347 mhm 343 I think I'm sorry
my apologies at 347 something like that
okay I was in the Val I'm painting you
act like I'm painting you in this light
you said you were at the bottom of yeah
it was different back then they didn't
know about uh different um yeah
everybody gets smarter in their 50s what
are you talking about he didn't know
about learning dis I wasn't diagnosed
with my learning disability till I got
to
college I was asked to
leave okay all right gentlemen yeah and
there are certain things that you're for
sure the smartest on if we did a quiz on
like 1990s Philadelphia Phillies trivia
you're smoking everybody bud I actually
wouldn't be good on that but uh some
literature stuff thanks for the yes end
some no I can't let him be right I'm
inam Warrior I'm I'm in a goddamn mental
mental battle well what would the
questions be you mean like if we all
took the SATs or something how do you
determine who's smarter first of all
you're throwing this at me like I've
thought this out I have not I would ask
us with the five we you know the five of
us you're really taking offense to this
the F the five of us inter act a lot
together if we all had to vote on who
dumbest sounds are on who the bottom if
we had to rank from a smartest to not as
smart who the number five person would
be most of the time it goes Kippy Luke
me you I think me and you are pretty
close you're pretty dumb I am very
you're undereducated it's true you have
no education basically but I excel in he
went to college for about five minutes
oh you dropped out too I got kicked out
first semester not too shabby my man man
he's got more time than you do I got
caught in the dorm you might be okay I
didn't you're not three or two or one I
didn't really go to
class after my freshman year after my
freshman semester MH and I was in hotel
and restaurant management after my first
semester or maybe my first year so that
second year was a wash it was just like
seminars about Ray Croc and seminars Bob
Thomas oh there yeah they would have
like somebody from McDonald's come and
like you know do like a
presentation it was a good restaurant
hotel and restaurant management school
uhhuh I couldn't figure out the system
though like how to book some we met Bob
Evans I wish went down to the Sausage
Factory I do remember at one point we
were doing how to check somebody into a
hotel at hotel management yeah that
makes sense yeah like I was like doing
front of like the front desk stuff I
couldn't get it I remember thinking to
myself I mean you're saying you can't
get that by the I I was I was thinking
by the time I'm in the field it'll all
be computerized the
field I mean by the time I'm boots I
would have been more of aier you know
what I mean where where you score
Cod SC blowing hes yeah it was a couple
of tugboats set them up to room 305
that's a lost art form isn't it the Kier
no I think that still bangs pretty I
think that's still B good ones I've
always been too scared but if you're in
like a Vegas hotel and you go up to the
conier
and you know I don't think the conier is
doing that that's ask him for some
Buffet tickets buddy you know where I
can score Fogo de CH
reservations heard you're the guy to see
about a ex
Benedict no you would go to the the
parking guys would straighten you out
with that that's what I'm saying the
that's that's like people from [__]
I've never done that what anything like
that
like like what we're talking about two
things rolled up to a stranger like
yo I've been in cars in certain cities
where the driver has been asked almost
immediately in a city where you go oh
then I take that back these drivers are
going to know that you know it's I
recant my statement then I've done that
I've been in the front seat in a small
ass just give me the bag yeah in a small
town being like yo what's up oh you give
me me that what up you know what I'm
talking about like I don't know what you
mean sir give a [__] [__] sir
this is a bus just I think I had him
just take me to a denies or
something I'll see myself
out that's [__] good um you're smart
technically like when it comes to the
cameras and stuff I'm good at three
things yeah in life I what's the what
what's an overall an IQ
test is what you're talking about sh I
wasn't talking about anything I was just
saying a natural dayto
day yeah I'm stupid that's not what I'm
saying poop in the
rug F make a boom boom on a rug uh I
think you are very smart in certain
aspects I'm just to find out I don't
know what those are yet but I'm sure are
you being serious or do you really think
I'm smart in certain aspects who do you
think I'm good at what when you say I
think you're one of the funniest people
I've ever met in my life hands down not
even close thank you I was talking to to
congratulations uh I think you're a
great actor thank you solid musician
Hollywood don't solid musician I got
sned at
DM bastards what we going to get a best
podcast on there YouTube streaming
service yeah somebody somebody making a
little you know doing some numbers sure
what are we doing over here uh yeah
that's it what you know what I don't
know I mean no I'm just complimenting
you think I'm good at problem
solving I think you're good at problem
causing yes I am if there's somebody
there was an Emy for that if somebody
can jam up a [__] open Easy Pass Lane
it's you all systems go I like guming up
the works Foley refuses to turn his key
causing trouble you asked me what the
deal with a food order was that you had
ordered while holding your phone in your
hand the other other day oh yeah how'
that ever work
out you ordered a Thanksgiving sandwich
I did and then I think I made you throw
up it did gave me got me very sick and I
only ate half of it and was only going
to eat half of it and I had it on
multi-grain bread and that was the only
thing that I had had that that far that
day you're feeling guilty that I said
publicly you had a Thanksgiving sandwich
so you have to go no no no no don't feel
guilty about I'm just I mean you say he
only had half of it was on Multi game
red I hadn't eaten all day I did only
had half of it the other half is still
in the in the in the fridge sure cuz I
figured it would be kicking if I left it
in a tra I know but if somebody said hey
open up the packaging it's just napkins
like when you were a kid and put the
pillows to make it look like your body
like filling the bottle of vodka with
water they'll never know oh they know H
up and need a stiff
drink [__] uh freak out one time I got
blamed for that and it wasn't me and it
bothered the [__] out of me I love that
the Vodka was frozen and they were like
this was you I'm like I'm [__] I was
like 19 I'm like I'm not going to hide
it I going to take it I was just going
to take it it was down the shore too see
I love that I love when I get blamed for
something that's not me because usually
it's me sure and when it's not it's just
like all right you guys are all wrong
about me the whole time M I'll be
Vindicated sooner or later I will have
my Justice in this life or another I'll
find the real
perpetrator all right let's see here
great question yeah home run of a
question did you have graduation indeed
we did okay 22 we all had to give a
speech had a fish
concert uh you all had to give a 22
people and you you had to sit through 21
speeches did your parents go to that or
they sure did really real proud man of
what but I graduated high
school was yeah it wasn't really a
school yeah it was it credit it was what
do you mean it wasn't a school there
were
classes no
grades
rooms those were those events were
always weird for me
specifically because those were the only
events that my mom and dad would have to
spend together ah right so it' be like
and they were like cordial enough that
like my dad would go sit close to you
know that's nice he wouldn't like go to
the opposite like unless it was like
such a big thing and they didn't they
obviously weren't coordinated but like
if he saw them he was like we're in the
same section or whatever you know type
thing uh if you would have played Sports
there would have been a lot of
that sure but as I got older it got less
and less sigs yeah buddies yeah yeah you
just trying to hurt my feelings with
that you're one of my buddies and we
smoke sigs all the time how far did your
sports get you yeah we're not on a team
though I was out there I was out there
brainstorming cranking and smoking
kicking back heaters like M uh MCC just
need a fat guy I can break us all
together we can double our powers a
stupid F guy not stupid only 342 out of
the
a go-getter somebody that shows a little
potential but just hasn't someone who
drops out the second year of college
yeah I can't it's so funny to me and
it's very YouTu I would just love to see
you behind the system of trying to check
like roleplay checking in somebody like
you're in a class you're in a lecture
room and you're role playing checking
someone into a marot I don't think I
ever got that far I thought you said you
didn't understand it I didn't like we
had like projects that we had to do but
it was never that was never an oral
presentation of it oh you never had to
actually do it I don't think so I don't
think I ever got to I think I sto you
went to cashier school and failed yeah
that's crazy you didn't even make it to
the point where they give you the
keyboard
dude oh that no I did do it on a
keyboard that's right I think you just
told us you did like a that's how we did
it we did it I didn't just make this up
but I never we never had like the
teacher walk up like hi I'm so and so
okay what can I do yeah I do remember
putting it into a computer system real
Antiquated too like this is
96 it sucked yeah I didn't want to do
that [__] it was just that black screen
with the green letters like the Matrix
Matrix code that was the computer I
bought to I brought to college with me I
told you it was an Epson it was an Epson
epic I think at floppy disc to do it I
wasn't going to do that [__] watching
porn on floppy disc couldn't yikes
nothing back then you're out there in
the streets yeah biting for your
lives that was that was never going to
felt bad cuz I I knew I'm like this is
not going to work I remember going on my
cousin's graduation I know that feeling
ATC like right before I went to college
and I'm like I will never never be here
this is never going to happen and to my
credit you know God loved them how you g
to spin
this here's me being the hero with this
story he want to know what I'm good
at I remember calling my dad this was
more football I was hard and I was
getting my ass kicked and I didn't like
it but I remember calling them a couple
weeks in the football camp and being
like I don't like it I want to get out
of here and they're like no you got to
stay you got you commit it you got to do
it all
right play hard ball you play hard ball
I'm G to throw the academic part into
neutral I just knew dude being in CL I
just
knew I like the cafeteria I like the
fraternity I like drinking or you know
going out I like doing drugs in a room I
liked all that stuff the ladies it was
all that was all great thead you even
being awesome for two years yeah Sports
across team that was all great I just
knew this is not this ain't me I mean
yeah I was never a good student I could
I could get by I was it was so much work
I was good at gaming the system of like
what I have to do what I can do what I
can miss what I can't miss where I have
to I only had so much attention and
bandwidth that I was like all right I'm
going to put it I have to put in into
this paper this week I hated those kids
not that I hate at you but like I thanks
I thought we were friends no I didn't
mean it like that like kids that would
be able to like get by like they could
not study the stuff and then at the end
of the year they would you know crush
the final or research or or what's it
called they study to the test and they
would get it dude I never I know but
there was classes where I would I was
sitting there being like what's this guy
talking about I remember going I I dude
I had an economics class that was that
was me in Fry's
class that was that was you in room
service
101 wait what rumor hold on you said
Pickle lettuce onions what did you say
yeah yeah bad I remember sitting in a
[__] economy
macroeconomics what's that mean like
bigger things I macroeconomics is like
the airplanes helicopters skyscrapers
what big thing spaghetti no it's like
bigger uh macro M's getting hungry it's
like currencies it's like all of the
things that make the economy like macro
like bigger picture economics hi buddy
Tbone can we get a definition on
macroeconomics microeconomics I'm an
expert in micro machines oh sorry loved
Micro Machines sure they were my
favorite love the guy that did the
commercial too the part of Economics
concerned with larger scale or general
economic factors such as interest rates
and National productivity yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah I understand that a little bit
GD it's like GDP that kind of [__] okay
and I dude it was that what was your
degree you had a degree in marketing
what were you doing in economics class
you have to take all those business
courses you have to take them dude it
was that I like literature but I I was I
was poor he'd give you like nine books
to read in like two months like dud what
are you talking about you got a rager
tonight I'm Rush chairman I got
responsibilities dude you think I got
time for this Rush chairman but I like
the idea of it I also like my psychology
class we studied
chra okay it was a psychologist or a
writer or something like that seem to
really retain it
uh
Sherie um that and a uh what's like the
St Finance it might have been like the
stock prices and calls and PSP that no
but it would be like if you buy you took
class Snickers and PD it got an A say
Snickers and pudding put it
he that have been valedictorian but I
remember sitting there going I ain't I'm
I'm G it was like my brain would hurt
and I would go like I would sit there
and go okay step by step this okay I got
this this all right next thing I I just
could just could and I failed those I
failed those I had to go back and retake
them in the summer which they really
just kind of [__] that's what I like
somebody that plays ball yeah there was
some sort of computer I had to make a
website brutal man that was like an
early 20000s too that would have been
like 2006 2007 we had websites back then
yeah it's crazy Facebook was out oh was
it good for
them sh out to Zuckerberg he knows what
he's doing another College Dropout yeah
Harvard though plus he had cash that's
what I always everybody he was all Caked
Up by then like he dropped out a Harvard
dropout still made it's like still made
he dropped out as a billionaire you know
what I mean like it's not like he he
wasn't passing the test he had a billion
dollars waiting for who's sitting around
for that yeah not not like a cafeteria
as much as the next guy but later uh
chemistry was like that for me I didn't
know what the [__] this guy was talking
about I just wanted to be like hey man
shut up put on a movie dude you're
you're hurting my brain you got the buns
and burner going making a grilled cheese
no by the time that that I got in school
all that stuff got got they took the
lines out cuz kids were smoking heaters
and stuff like that we didn't do
anything fun like that like experiments
and stuff I remember we did like some
type of version of the Frog We were
talking about that I can't remember
exactly what it was but we didn't have I
remember like I would go to turn them on
and nothing they weren't hooked up it
was all but they still give you the
goggles they would do like um what's it
hydrochloric
acid something cuz I got it in my eyes I
used one of those machines What machines
the eye machine oh the eyewash yeah yeah
they stuck me in it
mhm they stuck my stuck my head in it so
embarrassing I mean I hadn't used I had
turn that water on since the 70s yeah
that stuff comes out brown it's like a
sprinkler system dude my buddy squirted
me in the eye with it cuz I like flicked
his nuts or something like that and it
it was diluted thank God if it wasn't I
would have been blinded for life cuz I
wasn't wearing my my safety goggles
there's chicks in there man I those
things sucked anyway dude I hated when
they put something on you that you were
like I this you are already
self-conscious about how you look and
then in gym class they put like a penny
on you or something man you're fat I
doubt you looked good in a lab Cod no we
have lab Cod so I'm not that's not
Dexter's Laboratory lab Coates I think
we had lab coats why would you go Oxford
who T that's crazy lab coats yeah I
think we had lab coats we didn't have
lab coats no we definitely had pennies
we had oh man [__] pennies I maybe
that's what I'm thinking of that was
like a g- string on me that
thing that thing's when they broke out
the got the pennies I don't got the nips
for this oh man that was look like I was
wearing a fishnet
tub check out the jugs on Ryan over
there huh that was brutal just Ki be
playing kickball I'm too sexy for my
[__] man
you was P it was
brutal par short um Bros oh man I've
been shaking it one time I don't know if
we ever we did shirts and skins at a gym
that like they were like oh we're going
to play Bas we went up there and I
didn't realize there would be like
[__] 20 people running ball it was
like the goddamn Rucker and they're like
all right they like picked teams like
shirts and skins and we some guy on our
team [__] shredded I like we'll be
skins I was like
[__] dude that was just one of those
things of like you gotta own it dude sh
off just [__] I I I mean I fake pulled a
ham me had after the second quarter I
got a game tonight I can't do this
insurance
purposes if anybody gets me on film
playing basketball lose my contract yeah
with
Blimpy I don't know how to guard him man
his shoulders going one way his guts
going the other call that the crossover
that was before the that was the answer
before AI baby put the Zone in the
league to try to stop me bunch of ones
falling out of your
pity
change I go up for Rebound quarters are
falling out oh man I had that one time
that's had to have happened to someone
sh someone call sherson skins someone
pulls their shirt off and has change
stuck oh I did yeah as when I was
waiting tables if I would fall asleep my
jeans I would wake up with like a like
$2 on me just stuck everywhere it's my
boy Coin Star yeah I remember one time
in in school I was so furious with my
mom I want to say it was uh middle
school but she washed she washed clothes
and there was a pair of underwear stuck
in my pants and I didn't realize it and
it shook out at at school I had that
happen yeah you yeah thank God they were
mine oh thank God I was only dealing
with
skidmarks Patty's g string Dr what the
pair of
ho
Henry you what are they called runs what
are the what are the the marks called
they got runs in them they would say
right he be like when they get the the
not the tear but it's called a run panty
hose yeah that's what I said hose yeah
no these these were I I understand and
then I said a pair of her hose with the
runs I hat it when my mom wore panty
hose why I don't know
disr I mean where was she what disgrace
a pair of pants were you goddamn mother
you doing I mean you are something
else getting mad at your mother covering
up her hairy
legs is that what it's for makes you
look tan or something that's why they do
it right I think it was to keep you warm
I don't think so in the winter I think
it's to like you're not showing skin I
mean people wear them like all over the
you know sure I don't know if it's like
I'm sure warmth is a byproduct but I
think it's more of like a a color type
thing hide physical features such as
blemishes bruises scars
spider veins varicose veins all
F get air of get a pair of H on you I
think I put a pair on one time oh for
sure yeah definitely as a ski mask I put
him over my head oh yeah yeah uhhuh get
the other leg hanging
here the ones that go up above the just
above the knee you know what I'm talking
about thaty M that's that's a lost art I
feel that was big in that's what you
would see in the nudie mags that that's
a a businesswoman with the skirt and the
thing oh my God I'm listening you know
who does that very well
uh sorry I got
to the scene it's the Seinfeld where
George meets the girl on the subway oh
that's her she's the business woman and
she's got those tights with like the
ruffle not the ruffle but the design at
the top there's also a scene in Wall
Street with Charlie Sheen and Michael
Douglas where he gets into the backseat
of a limo with a lady and she has that
man yeah what do they call it's garer
belt right I don't know no the garter
belts the little like yeah so the thing
that comes up then there's like the the
legs scrunchy okay yeah no that's a g
belt holds up the stockings yeah those
things I think get let me get eyes on
that yeah take a
minute she'll be right back yeah the
guard belt holds up the stockings yeah
it's so it's like oh my God I can't we
can't show this on [__] I be flagged
on YouTube it's these things it goes
from the panties to the stockings
there's like a a
sterup you know all about that don't you
castanza empty calories and male
curiosity yeah Geordie boy that's right
uh all right this one's in the same this
is very School heavy this is from Tommy
love it yo ever argue with a teacher
that it's illegal to not let you go the
bathroom that's a it's illegal to not
let me go there's a certain type of dirt
bag who starts quoting their rights in
things where rights aren't being
infringed upon that I respect this is
America you Flex it if you got it baby
yeah yeah that is uh that that is trashy
that was a big thing with us is uh cell
phones hit uh when we were in ninth gr
eighth or ninth seventh eighth nth grade
kids started getting them right uh
mainly it was like emergency type things
and they would so all through high
school we everybody had one at that
point uh and you weren't allowed to have
you were allowed after 911 you weren't
allowed to have it in school after 911
you were allowed to have it in school
but it wasn't allowed to be on because
like parent people were like if [__]
happens I want to be able to get in
contact you know what I mean that just
let me play snake in a bathroom um but
that was a b they would take your cell
phone of like hey give if they caught
you on it give it to me I'm taking it
you'll get it back at the end of the day
or the end of the year or the end of the
you know whatever they whatever their
threat was and everybody was like that's
my personal property this is America you
can't touch that [__] no it was I went
to school in the 90s there was none of
that [__] there was no rights back
then no like sewer gapo regime they told
you how it was yeah I was never a big
bathroom guy wander around wander around
the hall go and chill in the bathroom
they all smelled like smoke I hate it
being in there uh hung out in the back
of the class goofed around I would
definitely go take a long cruise I would
go uh yeah i' just get I'd just get that
all out I'd hit a vending machine sure
maybe go get a Swiss one of the Swiss
Iced Teas our bathrooms were littered
with I I bet it was similar in yours wet
toilet not wet toilet paper glob on the
ceiling yeah that was elementary school
for us we were early adop lot of pencils
in the in the drop ceilings sharp ones
throw it up there David Letterman style
this one I don't I don't even understand
this is from Ryan $10 homie never had
one red is a garbage for family velcro
the remote to a traffic cone so it
doesn't get lost traffic cone is a
little
excessive um I've seen that done where
they have it that's like the H cap on
the bathroom key at the gas station
that's crazy a cone is crazy if you have
an orange cone in your living room I
guess you'll always find it though but
you know what I love the way they smell
you ever smell an orange cone have I
smelled on the inside what am I of
course I have smells so good sometimes I
would bite one just to [__] get them
in there I know you did
fatty I think it's made out of the same
stuff Peeps are yeah no I know that yeah
that rubber smell will get that
plasticky [__] sink your teeth in
your blood runs
cold uh I've seen it where the where
friends or cousins had you know the dad
chair or whatever the velcro and it was
on there so you never lose never lost it
sure we weren't we didn't we didn't
apply to that what we like to do is it
gets
lost huge argument scream at somebody
somebody gets screamed at my mom rips
the cushions off the couch and where is
it Terry and then find it and you know
then move on about our day never an
apology yeah no um yeah that's uh we
were looking for trouble we never did
any of that never like no no system we
weren't smart we were just like whatever
just deal with it there was never any no
system also never a back never a back on
our remotes never ever ever um got to be
able to flip the batteries yeah you got
to be able to spin them pull no P yeah
pull it out put it back in get a couple
more clicks out of it dude there was way
too long where we were taped for like a
very very ve like multiple generations
of multiple remotes we were just Scotch
T what you're in it you're in it yeah so
like back in the day replacing those
remotes was that that's like a trend of
like what we talk about on the show of
like stuff being available like the
backs of the remotes were off cuz you
couldn't get a new remote you know what
I mean like what are you going to call
[__] the cable provider have them
send one out for $92 it's like you live
in now you can just be like oh my phone
can turn into a room remote it's like
the technology and they're way cheaper
it's like they you know before I
remember the first universal remote we
ever got to make the V probably the VCR
the DVD player and the TV work at the
same time it was Square weird blew my
mind remember the one remember the one
that had the extra stuff you slid the
top up down and there was more buttons
underneath it they never did anything
like a cover what were they plan that
was like picture and picture and picture
and picture you what were they planning
for man where did you think this was
going we had one man I as a kid it
flipped down so like a cell phone kind
of there was like that same thing that
would slide up this one flipped down now
probably like 2 and a half inches or
whatever and hey how you doing a lot of
lot of fun with that bad boy Dad it's
for you it's your
secretary uh all right let's see here
this was some handsome Foley senior
portrait first time long time never had
one read you rich boys have wooden
hangers yet or you still rocking the
plastic ones like us bozos plastic but
ours have like a little felt on them I
hate those we upgraded um all of our
hangers I think we moved into the new
apartment we we're mostly plastic we
have some wood ones for bigger jackets
mhm you know what I mean like I think we
might have a set of like seven wood ones
and I think they're in the hall closet
for jackets cuz like a bigger jacket
will you know flimsy out those but I'm
pure plastic Johns like all the way
through hangers are really the bane of
my existence I don't like hangers I like
when they're all the same
but for so long I've always had so many
so many extra and like broken ones and
this one and that one my mom had one
that was covered in yarn the whole thing
was in yarn oh I remember those I think
those were for like 9s and stuff great
for her hose I think cuz they were like
softer like for the they were a little
more yeah not going to tear or pull the
material yeah keep your strap on intact
know you're B they refer not 90s but
like finer materials I think it was
delicates things you would wash in Wool
light in the sink my mom's still banging
with that stuff really yeah sweaters and
stuff I guess oh okay I remember I
coming home not like a teddy or
something no what a nice lady I like
that scat you're running used that wool
Light commercial and it was some like
some like single lady like a like a
working girl you know what I mean she
comes
home came up from the office and she'd
like wash her like like I don't know
slip you know what a slip is MHM yes man
yeah oh I'm hard all charged up
this a after dark um I remember coming
home man there was a time when my sister
was how old are you you're 47 47 about
to be 48 so when my sister and brother
were in I want to say like junior high
high school sweaters hit heavy so you
were probably
in Early College maybe yeah sweaters
were big like dude it was like The Arrow
pastels the all of the gaps there's Old
Navies everybody sweaters were [__]
huge when the cotton v-neck came back
from the 80s when they came back
sometime in the 9s like the ones that
looked they were like they would be
white but then they would have like a
strip here they were very like Catholic
schooly you know Ivy leagy kind of
things those things with a white t-shirt
underneath it and a rip pair jeans yeah
it was it was it was that kind of stuff
so it's probably like what year would
that be like late '90s MH mid to late
90s yeah they were uh they they they
just started wearing sweaters they
couldn't dry them dude I would come home
on [__] laundry day trying to eat you
know make ilos and sit there and Munch
down there'd be sweaters all over the
[__] house laid out on the counters
the [__] T it's like a goddamn sweat
shop in this joint I'm trying to eat I'm
trying to eat a bowl of Cocoa Puffs was
brutal I remember being like can we do
can we [__] dry they're everywhere
man we at one of those wooden things the
hanger the racks yeah we never had that
they sucked we had a closed line way
back in the day I love a closed line
till the Hornets took her over and you
had to take it out to cut the grass sure
and once wait you have the one that look
like the antenna yeah oh man it was
concreted into the thing like somebody
dug a hole poured concrete 9B of
concrete in there like the things that
they used to show that the tornadoes
coming in movies yes something like that
it had like wires in between it look
like an umbrella without the covering
yeah real big it was like a big Square I
mean it was bigger than this table for
sure yeah don't you have to have a dog
chained in the yard to have one of those
we did shout out to Rusty in an
unfinished uh in an unfinished dog
housee was just plywood that thing that
thing had a couple leaks in the first
house we had a Mountaintop we had a nice
backyard and we had a nice I think she
had two of them clothes lines from like
you know the the house like where like
they had a little deck so like if you
walked out on the first floor you'd be
able to you know roll like it had a a
thing on it so it could roll and you'd
be able to pull the laundry in so you
wouldn't have to walk all the way down
and then you know when you put something
on there you send it out sheets hanging
on that thing in a spring day man talk
about a little Slice of Heaven running
through that smelling the summer in it
and then at night getting put to bed in
one of those could still smell the the
grass and the day on it yeah no when you
had a bowl of kicks waiting for you the
next morning that's clean living buddy
take me back there and leave me there
you know what I'm saying kid I picture
you going back now someone's living in
that house I'm back I would go back to
that house in a heartbeat my brother has
driven by it a few times when they uh
when they dropped the kid off at Camp um
yeah that that's I dream about that
house the most like being in that house
you know what I mean sure I don't I mean
I'm uh we still have the house that I
grew up in for you know the first uh you
know whatever like you were a baby there
no three that's a baby three or four
yeah okay yeah three or four we moved in
there yeah that was my baby house I
would love to go back to that um how
long for him to be back in that house
till he goes this place stinks this
place stinks
everything with you is Rose is everybody
alive every everybody's there like my
cousin still live next door no you're
going back to that house have they
remodeled it and stuff no it's that how
what do you mean so I get to it's it's
the way it was sure my dad there no it's
reality now who's going to do the cook
it jam up uh yeah I don't know they tore
down they tore down the you haven't been
back since you haven't even driven by
somebody lives there I get arrested you
can drive by you can't be that attached
to it you yeah haven't even gone and
seen it I look at it on Google Maps
every once in a while oh that's not
creepy
what let me get this is that weird you
never do that no you never look at like
your old house or like somewhere on like
Google Earth or something no I couldn't
care less huh all right yeah I mean I
kind of get it if you're like I get it
every night we used to have a
mountainous on Lake wall and paulp pack
that I try to find on Google Earth man
this place was the
tits I can't find it it's got tear down
right all over and no it was so nice
they build it cuz they were they they
were they build houses so so my stepdad
built it it was sick so sick the top
level was there had a a a air hockey
table on top of a bear rug and the top
man that's clean living right there dude
the whole the whole second floor was
like a loft it was like a log cabin
that's like a proper nice cabin dude
they buil I mean they were Builders so
they like they built this house for like
their whole family to use like they
would all go up there and man the top
row is kids the top floor that's where
the thing was that's where the air
hockey table was and then there was a
row which seemed like seven but it was
probably like
five uh single beds so like we'd all get
there me and my cousins we run up you'd
claim your bed for the weekend right on
the lake you're down there fishing
stealing talking about I haven't been
able to find it and I think it's gone
now that he's pass I asked him before if
he remembered the thing remembered the
address he said no how longar I couldn't
find it how long were you going there a
couple
years a good chunk of my childhood
didn't you use I thought remember you
telling me you used that in that like
when you were like 16 you and your boys
would go up there was that a different
one no no no no this they sold this
probably when I was uh yeah maybe like
15 I think we we stopped going they got
rid of it when they got the first uh
they they got rid of that they get a
shore house yeah there you go out with
the old you know what I mean it's also
like that was fun as a kid you're
running around nature doing all that
stuff it's like once you know you're
trying to see some [__] ladies in
some panty hoose on a boardwalk it's all
over go get your G
belt and a't going to do it uh but we
got to wrap it up gang what a fun one
boys nice little family episode as Kippy
said uh in the beginning there grab some
tickets come see us May 9th at Town Hall
it's the biggest show we've ever done
grab the squad come out and see us Kippy
and I co- headline play some ay with the
crowd and grab what's left of the card
game before they're gone and you are
hitting me up yo what's going on with
the card
they're going to be gone going to be
gone and I'll tell you this I tell you
all the time gang we love you see you
next week peace peace